one of the convicted killers at the
center of the popular Netflix
docu-series making a murderer is asking
for his life sentence to be reduced
brendan dassey's legal team is
announcing today they're petitioning the
governor of Wisconsin to grant him
clemency
when dasi was 16 years old he confessed
to helping his uncle kill photographer
Teresa Halbach but critics and his
lawyers claimed assy was coerced into a
false confession he served more than 12
years in prison in an episode of the
popular wrongful conviction podcast
released today
dassie spoke from prison to host Jason
Flom only on CBS this morning we spoke
to Flom and dassey's attorney Laura and
I writer we had spent almost half his
life behind bars
convicted murderer brendan dassey's
legal options have been exhausted is
this your last option you know I'll
never say never this is our best option
now his attorney Loren eyewriter is
turning to Wisconsin's new Democratic
governor we're filing a petition for
executive clemency with governor Tony
Evers of Wisconsin in 2007 dasi and his
uncle Steven Avery were sentenced to
life in prison for the murder of Teresa
Halbach the burned remains of the 25
year old photographer were found on the
Avery family property along with her key
and car avery whose blood was found in
that car has claimed he was framed at
the time of halbachs murder Avery was
suing Manitowoc County and its former
sheriff he'd been released from prison
in 2003 after DNA evidence exonerated
him of a rape charge for which he'd
served 18 years the case became a
sensation when Netflix released the
docu-series making a murderer
amid the murder investigation dasi who
is intellectually limited was
interviewed by police four times in 48
hours without a lawyer or parent present
the 16 year old eventually confessed to
helping his uncle rape and kill Halbach
but Nightrider says dasi was fed
information by investigators dasi
quickly recanted first to his mother
while still in the interrogation room
you're convinced he's innocent he's
absolutely certain that he's innocent
music industry executive Jason Flom is
behind the careers of stars like Katy
Perry and Lord as a member of the board
of the Innocence Project he fights for
criminal justice reform Flom spoke to
dasi for his podcast wrongful conviction
it's dassey's first interview since
going to prison I just wanted it all
over with so I said whatever they wanted
to hear you know most people grow up as
I did with believing that law
enforcement or out to help us right
they're people you call when you need
help did you have that same idea when
you went in there yes anything I can do
to help them you know I would what do
you hope the podcast does false
confessions are a problem that I want to
bring as much attention to as we can
according to the Innocence Project in
about a quarter of wrongful convictions
later overturned with DNA evidence
defendants made false confessions
admissions or statements to law
enforcement among the reasons people
falsely confess real or perceived
intimidation by law enforcement
exhaustion stress and in some cases
mental limitations or limited education
when Brendan Dassey was in special
education he was in tenth grade
he required an aide to sit next to him
in the classroom to help him understand
the teachers spoken sentences then shift
him into the interrogation room where he
was barrage with 1,500 questions over
three and a half hours you don't have to
be a lawyer to understand how an
interrogation like that would overwhelm
someone like Brendan Dassey what gives
you hope that this governor will grant
you clemency governor eavers comes to
this office from the Wisconsin Board of
Education he's an educator
he's been around special education
students like Brendan as for clemency
dasi does not fit the criteria for a
pardon and the wisconsin governor has
said he won't consider commutations
which reduce the length of a sentence
CBS news legal analyst Ricky cleamen why
file for clemency now well you have a
new governor and you have a new governor
who has expressed himself unequivocally
about being interested in social justice
and criminal justice reform so they
believe as his lawyers that they may get
a receptive audience here
that's nightriders hope this is his best
shot and the moment is now the moment is
now for Brennan to come home he will
turn 30 years old later this month he is
not eligible for parole for another
nearly 30 years in the past Teresa
halbachs family has said they believe
the right men are behind bars for her
murder the former prosecutor in the case
has said the same thing but it's it's
worth reminding people that in 2016 a
judge ruled that dassey's confession was
coerced he was hours away from being
released when a federal appeals court
blocked it and it's interesting his
lawyer makes a very compelling case when
she said when he was in tenth grade he
had to have someone sit by him just to
translate what the teacher was saying no
this this confession is extremely
controversial and it is also worth
pointing out that there was no physical
evidence actually linking dasi to the
crime big picture 25% of overturned
convictions had a false confession
involved in amazing it's a real issue
all right interesting to see what
happens